france inter françois bayrou bonjour
bonjour et bienvenue à notre micro ou et
emmanuel macron on a envie de vous poser
la question parce que ça fait presque
dix jours maintenant qu'il a été réélu
et à part quelques mots lancés devant
les micros à cergy la semaine dernière
on ne sait pas vraiment quel est son
agenda quelles sont ses priorités on ne
sait pas non plus qui portera son action
quelle sera la ligne de la campagne pour
les législatives
que veut-il pour ce second quinquennat
ou va-t-il pouvez-vous françois bayrou
nous éclairer ce matin tout cas je peux
avoir une opinion
sans être ni les gestes quelque chose
entre le porte parole du président de la
république
la question principale c'est la fracture
du pays
et c'est une fracture qui est à la fois
sociales c'est fascinant si vous
regardez dans les sondages la
répartition des votes
qui a voté pour qui et alors vous
apercevez que
le tout ce qui qui sont
la base de la pyramide sociale ceux qui
travaillent ce qu'ils sont à la retraite
ce qu'ils sont sont évident sont
beaucoup plus impacté par le vote
extrême
que ce qu'on appelle sommet de la
pyramide je suis pas sûr que ça soit un
sommet je suis pas sûr que toujours il
le mérite mais c'est à dire ceux qui
gagnent bien qu'ils ont voté globalement
pour vous pourrez manu le malin et les
autres qui exhale alors ceux qui gagnent
bien et puis il ya une question de
locataires ou propriétaires patrimoine
et ça et ça fait des faits des
fracturations autrement dit il ya une
dimension sociale du vote qui est très
importante et puis il ya une dimension
c'est pas comment on peut dire
démocratique et culturelle
les gens qui ont ont
l'impression parfois la certitude qu'on
ne les entend pas qu'on ne les reconnaît
pas qu'ils n'ont pas leur place quand on
les entend pas derrière les micros et
qu'on ne les voit pas derrière les
écrans je pense que l'écran de
télévision est une frontière que qui
voit-on sur l'écran et qui n'y est
jamais et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il ya toute cette contestation qui va
vers le monde politique vers le monde
mais vers le monde des médias aussi il
ya quelque chose là dedans qui est d'une
fracture d'une rupture entre n'ont pas
de france mais plusieurs france et mon
sentiment à moi ma certitude à moi c'est
que la prochaine étape le prochain
gouvernement son but principal premier
prioritaire
doit être
les chemins pour réconcilier le pays
pour
cicatriser et pour apporter
au plus grand nombre possible la
reconnaissance à laquelle ils ont droit
voilà ma vision on va on va en parler
vous allez nous dire quels sont à votre
avis les pistes que doit suivre le
président de la république mais là pour
répondre à la question de que nicolas
vous a posé il est absent pour l'instant
il ne donne pas parce qu'ils ne donnent
ils ne donnent aucune indication et du
coup ils laissent pardon mais la place
médiatique aux extrêmes que vous
coup vous dénoncez vous même d'accord
pour dire que il n'est pas encore
installé dans ses fonctions comme vous
savez il ya une espèce de deux rites
républicains qui fait qu'après
l'élection le conseil constitutionnel
doit proclamer qui est élu ça se passera
jeudi je crois et puis après le
président de la république doit être
installé dans ses fonctions
solennellement et puis ça tombe dans la
période du 8 mai du neuf mais vous savez
il ya des des rendez-vous qui sont très
importants il a 10 ans et à strasbourg
leurs repères et internationaux rappelle
que c'est le 9 mai que poutine organise
l'espèce d'autocélébration
sur accents de menaces
sur la place rouge et qu'il y allèrent
quelque chose évidemment qui qui qui
marque profondément ce que doit être
l'action la réflexion la parole du
président de la république française on
met dans cet entre deux c'est un autre 2
que les institutions ont voulu que notre
pratique
démocratique a voulu vous l'avez dit
françois bayrou et vous l'avez analysé
le pays est fracturée emmanuel macron a
promis une nouvelle forme de gouvernance
un deuxième quinquennat qui ne serait
pas dans la continuité du premier qu'est
ce que ça veut dire exactement
est-ce que vous pouvez là encore nous
l'expliqué où nous dire à quoi ça
pourrait ressembler
gouverner autrement oui
l'accent doit être mis parce qu'ils ont
là qui ont la responsabilité du
gouvernement
et des autres autorités du pays
l'accent doit être mis sur un projet
politique j'ai essayé de décrire ce
qu'ils devaient être alors ce projet
politique que j'appelle de
réconciliation c'est aussi un projet de
mobilisation
si vous regardez la situation de la
france alors vous dites qui a des
deschamps tiers fin des programmes des
projets de
de la planification à mettre en place
président de la république a évoqué
l'écologie mais de manière floue par
dont on n'arrive pas à comprendre il dit
je choisirais la priorité sera gelée que
l'écologie mais concrètement vous faire
alors moi je pense que dans l'écologie à
trois questions le principal la première
c'est l'énergie
parce que cette question là comment
produire de l'énergie sans émettre de
gaz à effet de serre qui entraîne le
réchauffement de la planète
cette question là elle appelle des
réponses qu'ils soient pas des réponses
floues ou de houe de bonnes intentions
il ya deux manières de produire de
l'électricité sans émettre de gaz à
effet de serre ya les renouvelables et
ya le nucléaire tout le reste
renforce les émissions renforce
considérablement
c'est en partie la responsabilité de
l'allemagne renforcent considérablement
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre ça
c'est le premier grand chapitre et il ya
eu de ce point de vue la désorientation
et un deuxième grand chapitre c'est la
biodiversité
comment
peut-on faire pour que le sol la nature
produisent en matière agricole on en a
besoin produisent est cependant protège
le seul et les mécanismes naturels qui
font que l'on va on va retrouver des
espèces ayant une troisième sujet qui
est notre manière de vivre le tout ce
qui est de l'ordre de au fond une vie
plus frugale d
une économie qui permettent de recycler
un très grand nombre de choses par
exemple je trouve c'est une opinion
personnelle on ne devrait plus jamais
exporté de déchets les déchets qu'on
envoie dans des pays lointains avec des
gens misérables pour être traité que
tous les pays occidentaux envoie dans
des pays lointains pour être traitées
dans des bidonvilles ou ou des régions
africaines on devrait les traités nous
mêmes on devrait en faire une règle ça
veut dire aussi que l'europe doit être
assigné à cette nécessitait pas si j'en
sens et vous vous dites la priorité du
prochain quinquennat la priorité absolue
doit être de réconcilier ces frises et
de france où ses 240 milles et de
cicatriser le reconnaître oui mais
pensez-vous pardon que la mesure phare
du programme des manuels mâcon pour ce
deuxième quinquennat celle qui a marqué
la campagne c'est-à-dire la retraite à
65 ans à 64 ans soit en mesure de
réconcilier les français françois bayrou
honnêtement il arrive quelquefois en
politique que les présentations soit pas
absolument idéal ça vous arrive à la
radio
et ça nous arrive et ça arrive aussi
dans le monde politique la présentation
n'était pas idéal le la question est
très simple est ce qu'on doit rechercher
l'équilibré entre les retraites qu'on
verse aux pensionnés et les cotisations
que versent les salariés pour assurer la
charge de ces retraites pour l'instant
cet équilibre n'est pas trouvée à telle
enseigne que le gouvernement précédent
hollande par une loi touraine avait fait
en sorte de déplacer le curseur de la
retraite progressivement et c'était
d'une certaine manière un accord général
qui avait été trouvé autour de ce
rééquilibrage ce rééquilibrage qu'est ce
qu'il doit dire aux de dire des choses
très simples la première bien entendu on
va pas traiter de la même manière les
gens qui sont entrés très tôt dans le
travail qui ont commencé à travailler
très tôt dans leur vie et ceux qui sont
entrés après des études longues il et
juste que le traitement ne soit pas le
même donc avantage à ceux qui ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt
deuxièmement on ne peut pas ne pas tenir
compte des métiers pénibles
parce que je chatte fois que je vois ces
jeunes hommes qui étendent du bitume sur
le trottoir avec une taloche en plein
soleil je me dis que c'est pas juste
qu'on les traite comme quelqu'un qui a
un travail administratif par exemple et
qui est moins atteints par par les
maladies professionnelles est quand même
notamment et troisième manches olaf
troisièmement moi je pense qu'il faut
beaucoup agir par incitations
je pense qu'on peut qu'on peut tenir
compte du choix des gens il ya beaucoup
de gens qui choisissent et choisiraient
de travailler plus tard s'il y trouvait
des avantages et tout ça doit se faire
parce que ça n'est pas c'est pas pour le
gouvernement que c'est fait c'est fait
pour que tous ceux qui sont à la
retraite puisse toucher à la fin du mois
une retraite qui suivent l'inflation
donc vous voyez aujourd'hui vous avez
sept ou huit français sur dix qui sont
contre cette réforme
parce qu'on n'a pas expliqué et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai défendu alors
c'est pas du tout au rien d'un
gouvernement j'ai observé depuis très
longtemps puisque c'est une idée que je
défends depuis 2007 j'ai observé depuis
longtemps que ce qui est un obstacle sur
le chemin d'être ses décisions
c'est le blocage du pays où la menace de
blocage du pays où le fait qu'on
orchestre qu'on
mette le tambour et la grosse caisse
autour de l'idée mais puisque c'est
comme ça on va bloquer le pays et on va
passer par là 49,3 et ongles oui le 49-3
c'est un peu du même ordre or ma
conviction profonde c'est que si on a un
gouvernement que dans une démarche de
deux rencontres et d'explication avec le
pays qui est absolument respectueux de
la vérité et et bien je suis persuadé
mois que les français pourraient si vous
me posez la question d'accepter ça
quitte à perdre qui t'est ce ils
auraient fait ça n'est pas grave si on
perd et bien c'est le gouvernement qui
assume la responsabilité
jean luc mélenchon à ces propositions
également pour réparer la fracture donc
vous parliez la retraite à 60 ans le
smic à 1400 euros que pensez vous de ces
propositions
je pense que pensent tous ceux qui qui y
compris ceux qui participent à tout ça
je reprends l'exemple que je citais la
retraite à 60 ans le parti socialiste
lui même a mis en place une réforme de
touraine qui porte la retraite à 63 64
65 ans je rappelle pour ceux qui nous
écoutent qu'est ce que c'est cette
réforme touraine l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation allonge le temps de
cotisation le temps de travail
nécessaire pour obtenir une retraite à
taux plein on la longe de un trimestre
tous les trois ans jusqu'en 2035 pour
arriver à quarante trois ans l'entrée
dans la vie active des français c'est 22
ans et demi presque 23 ans la moyenne de
l'entrée dans la vie active y compris
vous et moi en femme non moi j'étais
entré plus tôt mais est donc cette
moyenne d'entrer dans la vie active
vingt deux ans et demi plus 43 ans de
cotisations comme vous calculez très
très bien et le que le calcul mental est
redevenu j'espère redeviendra une
priorité à la france importe combien 22
ans et demi et 43 ans apporte à 65 ans
et demi c'est sale c'est ça la ville mal
fait dans les fers dans le faire on part
à la retraite entre 60 et 61 ans c'est
ce que dit le cdh et non par la retraite
en france à
63 presque 63 62 ans et demi et je n'ai
pas de doute qu'il fera allongée si on
veut trouver l'équilibré si on veut que
l'on soit assuré que les que les
salariés ne soient pas assommés par des
prélèvements que leur fin du mois ne
soit pas amputée par des prélèvements et
que les retraités les pensionnés soit
assurés de leurs versements à la fin du
mois donc pour moi je pense que dire
dire
on peut revenir à 60 ans c'est
simplement un mensonge ça n'existera pas
sur les législatives un mot d'abord sur
l'accord conclu hier par la france et
insoumise et les verts en attendant
celui avec le parti socialiste et des
communistes cette force de gauche
peut-être majoritaire dit jean luc
mélenchon vous qui connaissez bien la
carte électorale vous le pensez aussi je
ne le crois pas mais ce qui s'est passé
là
et tenez vainement
extrêmement triste pour beaucoup de
français qui sont pas du camp
majoritaire triste triste je pense que
des socialistes et j'ai en tête tous les
noms de ceux qui ont exercé des
responsabilités dans ce grand courant
social démocrate du pays
voir
accepter leur parti signer la fin de
tout ce qu'ils ont fait la ruine de tout
ce qu'ils ont voulu faire je vais
prendre un exemple très simple c'est
cette idée a acté accepté dans les
accords qu'on allait désobéir aux
traités européens aux décisions
européennes alors vu de france si c'est
les français qui désobéissent ça peut
avoir dans la présentation à côté
sympathique je vais prendre deux
exemples qu'est ce qui se passe vous
savez que l'europe a interdit dès
molécules de produits phytosanitaires
pour l'agriculture et donc ça fait faire
un progrès pour la protection de la
santé et du biotope qu'est ce qui se
passe si demain l'espagne dit moi je
désobéis ray pas je n'accepterai pas
l'interdiction de ces produits qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe chez
les arboriculteurs français chez les ch
et les maraîchers français qu'est-ce qui
se passe
deuxième exemple et qui visait 2
aujourd'hui deuxième exemple deuxième
exemple on a décidé tous ensemble qu'on
allait imposer une fiscalité minimale
aux multinationales on a dit c'est plus
possible que vous continuez à ne pas
payer d'impôts en europe
nous allons vous imposer une fiscalité
minimale de 15 % pour ces sociétés là
c'est évidemment pas rien qu'est ce qui
se passe si le luxembourg l'irlande ou
les pays-bas décide de ne pas respecter
cette règle la vérité il ya des
sanctions mais c'est tout ça le regarde
et la pologne regardez la hongrie qui
désobéit je ne crois pas que ce soit
aussi simple on devra faire l'inventaire
de tout ça il unit à d'europe que si
tout le monde respecte les décisions
prises en commun c'est exactement la
même chose dans une copropriété c'est
exactement la même chose dans un club
c'est c'est une c'est un ferment c'est
une c'est une puissante
annonce de dissolution la vérité c'est
que derrière tout ça se dissimule l'idée
que la france pourrait sortir de l'union
européenne s'étaient d'ailleurs leur
projet dit ya cinq ans sourit jean-luc
mélenchon l'a redit ce week end n'y a
pas de frénésie tu n'en as pas de frais
dit excusez moi frais xix je connais
jean luc mélenchon depuis longtemps
c'est une blague c'est une intox
parce que si vous décidez qu'en europe
un pays aussi importants que la france
ne respectera pas les règles alors c'est
la sortie de la france et la fin de
l'europe parce que les autres pays
comment comment voulez vous qu'ils
acceptent que que l'un des membres de
notre entente de notre organisation
européenne qui est au passage essentiel
pour pour la paix
peut se peut ce s'abstraire peut
s'éloigner peut refuser les décisions
qu'on a prises en sabah et rossi jean
luc mélenchon était en face de vous il
vous dirait qu emmanuel macron lui-même
n'a pas respecté la règle des 3% encore
une fois ceci est une blague la règle
des 3%
devrait pas dire des choses comme ça
elle n'a pas été respectée parce que
tous ensemble nous avons décidé que le
moment était si grave qu'on n'avait pas
à respecter des règles budgétaires dans
une situation comme celle-là je prends
un deuxième exemple très très vite voyez
ce que poutine est en train de faire
vous voyez ce qui se passe en ukraine
avec un peuple courageux qui se bat de
manière totalement inattendue jean luc
mélenchon avait dit que la guerre et que
rien n'était perdu que les ukrainiens
avaient perdu la guerre c'est ce qu'il a
dit à vos micros que c'était fait que
voilà un peuple qui se bat qui résistent
comme il peut qu'ils infligent des
défaites y compris à un ennemi surarmés
et on annonce que la france va sortir de
l'otan comment ça va être entendu par
les ukrainiens et par les russes
commencent une décision de cet ordre qui
est une décision en réalité pour couper
les jarrets de tous ceux qui résistent
comment cette décision là elle peut être
accepté par le grand courant social
démocrate français qui a eu le pouvoir
pendant si longtemps par les écologistes
ce que je viens de dire sur les produits
phytosanitaires et tout ceci
pardonne moi de le dire je connais très
très bien
des gens de gauche beaucoup j'ai été
ministre de l'éducation nationale et
j'ai avec eux sur des choses
essentielles des ententes profonde c'est
aujourd'hui un désespoir pour un grand
nombre tous ceux qui avaient bâti cela
je pense à jacques delors par exemple
dans
peut-être il nous il nous entend
comment peut-il accepter ça comment
peuvent-ils signé la fin de tout ce pour
quoi ils se sont battus moi je crois que
cet accord n'ira pas jusqu'au bout parce
que je pense qu'il y a suffisamment
d'hommes et de femmes de conscience qui
ne l'accepterons pas allons aux
standards de france inter nous attend
bahija bonjour et bienvenue oui bonjour
quand vous écoute
bonjour monsieur béraud
pour résumer un peu votre propos je
trouve que vous êtes une caricature du
monde politique et des notables de la
politique vous avez été responsable de
la planification ces dernières années
après avoir été évincé du monstre de la
justice on sait pour quelles raisons
vous avez parlé on a beaucoup cité cet
exemple des pommes de terre et des
chiffres qui vont pommes de terre
produites en france revenait sous forme
de chips d'acheter à l'échelle
européenne
ce a pour impact
d'atteindre le pouvoir d'achat des
français allant vous vous dites que
mélenchon n'arrivera pas à fédérer des
gauches autour de lui pour les
législatives moi j'espère qu'il va y
arriver vous aviez une question by yahoo
bah oui alors dites nous ont dit non
alors une question qui est celle du
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat est
absolument enfin mis à mal le pouvoir
d'achat des français et des européens
dans leurs banques dans leur globalité
et mis à mal par les politiques mises en
place un fois par la macro ni à la fois
par une certaine frange de l'europe qui
ne respecte pas les traités européens
aussi bien sur la fiscalité qu'il y a on
le sait des paradis fiscaux en europe et
qu
on va on va rester sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat déjà que que vous posez
et la retransmettre à françois bayrou
préoccupation qui a été au coeur de la
campagne électorale qui reste au coeur
de l'air au sommet pardon des
préoccupations des français inflation
dont on a parlé avec philippe aghion à
ce micro hier quelle solution pour le
pouvoir d'achat en urgence la maintenant
dans des états de croissance atone de
contraintes budgétaires
étouffante ans la france fait les
solutions c'est d'abord l'aide qu'on
doit apporter à ceux qui sont dans le
dans le travail dans les salaires qui
sont ses vrais insuffisant ou dans les
retraites insuffisantes et il y a de ce
point de vue là on a parlé de chèques un
inflation il ya des réponses mais
surtout je voudrais mettre en évidence
ce que belge attisait à l'instant le
disais
on ne respecte pas les traités européens
mais elle soutient une proposition qui
vise à faire du non respect des traités
européens
la règle générale de une éventuelle
future majorité
vous voyez bien qu'il ya une
contradiction sur ce sur ce point et
quant à dire que
si j'ai quitté le ministère de la
justice c'est pour des raisons que tout
le monde connaît puisque c'est ce
qu'elle a dit je voudrais qu'elle
demande à jean luc mélenchon
personnellement si lui même n'a pas dé
réflexion à faire sur ce sujet
et expliqués en sous-texte pourquoi
parce que c'est la même mise en examen
sur la question des sur la question des
à son argumentaire ressources des
assistants parlement question de kevin
sur l'application de france inter
françois bayrou dévoile ce matin sa
ligne de conduite afin qu emmanuel
macron le nomme premier ministre un
point d'exclamation l'un à 3 rien n'a
droit qui vouvoie campagne pour matignon
mais ben je suis pas en campagne la
preuve c'est que c'est vous qui m'avez
invité je voulais faire et vous venir
et que on ne fait pas campagne pour ce
genre de choses mais je pense que c'est
un très grand sujet que le gouvernement
futur soit axée autour de ces questions
que nous avons évoqué ensemble le
président de la république a fait une
campagne sur ce sujet mais on a
l'impression que le monde politique dès
que la campagne présidentielle est finie
abandonne le le centre de gravité de ce
qui devrait être une obsession pour nous
dans vous lui demander de ne pas oublier
ses promesses et de choisir quelqu'un
qui aurait un projet jeu est-ce qu'on
peut mettre des mots françois bayrou
quelqu'un qui aurait un profil plus
politique que technique quelqu'un qui
aura un profil plus expérimenté que
jeunes est ce que c'est je je je est ce
que je déplore votre pensée oublions
tout ce qui pourrait
laisser penser ou alimenter l'idée que
ont fait en réalité des portraits-robots
c'est pas du tout ce à quoi je pense je
pense que
on a depuis très longtemps une rupture
avec les français qui est sur une chose
toute simple qui est la langue que l'on
parle le pouvoir les pouvoirs et vous
les recevez à votre micro à peu près
tous les jours les pouvoirs ont une
manière de s'exprimer peut-être une
manière de penser avec des idées des
concepts des mots extrêmement compliquée
qui fait que la plupart des français ou
un très grand nombre d'entre eux ne
comprennent même plus ce dont on parle
c'était une balle pour les techno
n'envisage a tragic c'est une c'est une
certitude
je n'ai je n'ai jamais oublié chaque
fois que c'était parfois des femmes
souvent des femmes mères de famille qui
disait je ne comprends pas ce que les
gens du pouvoir 10 et moins un banc bien
qu'ils ne comprenaient pas il ya des
hommes aussi qui comprenait bien sûr
mais vous voyez bien si l'on ne retrouve
pas le moyen de faire partager des idées
essentielles et simple en termes
essentiels est simple toute
réconciliation est impossible dernières
secondes 10 d'art question 10 secondes
le grand parti unique veulent certains
en macro ni avec vous tout le monde
dedans est ce que vous y êtes favorable
nous c'est un parti udc de la monarchie
comme dit christian jacob on a besoin de
deux
nécessités la première de ces nécessités
c'est l'unité on a besoin de rassembler
tous ceux qui veulent travailler
ensemble et la deuxième de ces
nécessités quelquefois on n'y pense pas
c'est le pluralisme il ya des
sensibilités différentes et il est
normal qu'elle soit reconnue comme il ya
parmi les français une nécessité de
reconnaissance faire et cela exige un
équilibre et je suis persuadé qu'on va
le trouver ça va avec edouard philippe
oui très bien qu'il va bien français
en tout cas la dernière fois que je les
ai vus c'est à dire hier il avait l'air
en pleine forme comme j'étais en pleine
forme et comme on a bien rigolé ensemble
mais on en reste là sur un sorbet sur un
sourire arrêtons-nous une seconde est ce
qu'on peut imaginer
qu'on se fasse la guerre à l'intérieur
de la majorité dans son lit la presse et
quand même si ce que vous envoyez par
comme mots d'une violence inouïe entre
clans plus thomas cronista clan fini
piste et bien on peut se poser la
question à la fois ça va accepter léa
salamé accepter qu'il y ait des gens qui
ne se reconnaissent pas dans les clans
qui pensent que la proche de la
politique ou d'une la proche de de cette
charge importante qu'on doit avoir pour
le pays ne s'accommode pas des clans et
encore moins des guerres de clans j'ai
pas toujours été d'accord avec edouard
philippe c'est de notoriété publique
mais enfin on a à construire ensemble et
7,7 nécessité la devrait s'imposer à
tous dans les mots j'ai insisté sur les
mots et dans les actes merci françois
bayrou clair merci d'avoir été à notre
micro ce matin il est 8 heures 49